Easter to me there's no like real
boozing on Easter it's Sunday afternoon
you go to church Easter stinks it stinks
but that's the classes I'll tell you
right now here's how we can ruin that
horseshoes my family during Easter at my
Aunt se's house sh God rest this is why
I have the top rated episode which just
pass a million by way I know Shane and
sagur are climbing on me I know it but
I'll tell you this my aunt C God Rest
her soul and her husband Uncle Bill was
a cop was that shooting Justified hey
now why you bringing up old [__] Split
Second decisions no they were they were
good people was a different time yeah
they were good people and uh you know
they had Easter Sunday and my family
would drink and then throw horseshoes
Jes and so there there would be kids
running around and then you'd have a
metal horseshoe like whizzing by your
head and like you'd be in your church
you know and then like you know somebody
would scream at you be like get a fat
away yeah and just sling a throwing
metal through the but I agree with you
in theory there's nothing classier than
Easter yes yeah but it sucks and I
always thought in horseshoes that I
wasn't good at it cuz I didn't have a
cigarette hanging out of my mouth that's
what I thought that's what I thought
made the uncles that good it was a
heiney you had to have a hinin and a Sig
hanging out of the mouth in the throw
you had to have that you had to have it
and they were and they they played
horses shoes during Easter Sunday and
then Easter Saturday we would do my
nanny would do a a pink ham and she'd
with a mustard vinegar glaze okay which
was real nice and then she would do uh
you know the sides and stuff yeah when
they when those Honey Baked started
getting popular the game that's a big
deal that was like we're going to get
the honey baked the spiral cut cheese
potatoes little cinnamon apples yes of
course but I'll tell you why Eed to can
kick rocks one pastels get the [__] out
of here interesting I hate that [__] H
Foley coming out against pastel yeah he
Tes the hard takes that H Foley early
early on in the
episode church is nice on uh Church on
Christmas no but I'm just saying you
know you have you have something nice on
it's the winter you're not going inside
you're hanging out in the back you're
goofing around you know what I mean you
maybe got a couple M&M's or some it's
not as proper it feels yeah dude [__]
Easter you feel like you're a used car
salesman I'm walking around in a pink
Blazer like a dick get out of here with
I will tell you one thing about Easter
there's what the the Easter cigarette
outside of the church oh nice grass is
coming in's a little bit of a breeze
little bit of a breeze you're still
sweating you're still sweating but the
sweat's being cooled by the breeze and
you're having a sigy outside the church
and the priest they're all looking at
you go I know what I'm doing but I'm
here I'm on the property I'm here I'm on
the property they were always waiting to
rip a heat that's remember the first
time he saw a priest ripping a ripping a
dart behind the rectory holy [__] yeah
he's like I got to have something you
know so Easter I think you're right
about that Easter does the the candy's
whack too it presents as the class I
don't like the candy and I don't like
you know the the Easter egg hunt the
basket hey hey hey what are we working
for here just I know you got to give it
to me there was only one that had a five
in it you know my aunt used to hide
these baskets so aggressively that
people would start crying me and my
cousins would start crying uh there was
no baskets she would hide them in places
my grandfather had did well and he built
his own house in in mutton toown Long
Island which is an area where Jennifer
Lopez mut Town doesn't sound nice mutt
Town SS behind a butcher no I know but
it's it's one of those things rich
people do where they're like you you'd
think it's not but it's it's stunning
and he had a 5,000 foot house which to
was huge big house and but here's the
problem when you hide
baskets kids start crying because you
look in a few places and people start
getting upset now and my aunt really
liked that cuz she was sick she DeMent
it yeah she didn't have children herself
and and when we people would start to
cry and she would just go look look look
harder work harder and we run up and
down the stairs and then we event find
it and then what was DET treat nothing
you know couple of pastel you know you
get a nice um Reese's duck I mean
Reese's what what is it a those were art
the peeps Reese's egg peeps can kick
[__] rocks Reese's egg the Cadbury I
do like a cadburry cream McFlurry cadry
Cream Egg love them a cadburry cream
McFlurry in London is nice holy [__]
really they're doing that over welcome
to the world oh welcome to Global I got
to get a pport that's all right yeah
it's not bad and uh the candy didn't
catch up until recently when I was when
we were kids it was the shitty low low
low offbrand chocolate bunnies that were
Hollow the wax choc and it was chemical
taste it sucks you had a chemical taste
and plus I remember was it a Russell
Stover what what kind of bunny did you
get Russell Stover I'd be all right with
Russell Stover was the one that was kind
of midgrade yes midgrade respectable
your father still has a job you got
Russell Stover he got a Bonus that year
lint is a little Next Level lint who was
getting lint that's I didn't have that I
didn't have that till 32 yeah a TCH of
sea salt sea salt it the lint bunny is a
nice bunny huh the lint bunny is a good
bunny I remember one year getting a
solid white chocolate crucifix and I was
like can I see if you can even find can
I eat I would love to see a solid white
chocolate I like can I eat this crazy
that was definitely something they gave
out to for The Clue clux Clan by the way
it's real it's real I love you can get a
white chocolate crucifix how do you feel
about the white chocolate oh sucks I'm a
fan here's what I like I love it I like
it in ice cream my favorite flavor in
hodas is a white chocolate raspberry
truffle ice cream that's good when
gadiva had their ice creams and they
were only around for a few years in the
Glory Days of the late '90s the early a
early 2000s they had a white uh
chocolate raspberry ice cream white
chocolate raspberry in ice cream might
be one of the greatest flavor
combinations but as an actual candy I
don't like it the only one that kind of
hangs in there is the Hershey's cookies
and cream of course that's a little
different though it was so classy to me
it was so like you get it once a year
when it comes I love it I think looking
back I don't know if I love the taste
but I love the idea of it there's a
pageantry to Easter the flowers the
church and stuff it it is in theory
classy so we put that number one we're
ignoring by the way uh Islamic and
Jewish holidays here not because we're
not inclusive but I don't have any
experience do you gentlemen no I do not
we don't have any experience with